she opened the Chanel Fashion Show in
Paris as a mother what is it like for
you to see her and grow up and become
her own person at such a young age and
become so successful well I think it's
so funny because everyone's been saying
Oh aren't you so proud of her and I was
like yeah but it has nothing to do with
that she did fashion shows I'm you know
I'm just proud of the young woman that
she is becoming and just the way she
handles herself I was excited for her
because this is a dream that she's had
and it just happened in the nicest way
possible I mean she she had a great like
debut fashion season and I think like
opening Chanel I kind of at very end of
the month was it was amazing and even
for me I went to that show and I did
Carl show for Chanel so for me just to
reconnect with Carl and then and then
that kiyah was in it was like a great
full circle moment yeah another full
circle moment was when you were in the
line oh that was great was that like the
fashion moment of the decade yeah last
month Cyndi reunited with the
supermodels she dominated the industry
with including Naomi Campbell and
Claudia Schiffer for the Versace runway
show it was such a great tribute to
Gianni and you know we were so happy to
be asked we were happy to support
Donatello in that second it was like
those 20 years just yeah and then when
we walked off the runway everyone got
very choked up yeah did you guys get all
nervous behind the the runway or was it
just an excitement sighting moment
nervous we were laughing and joking
until about 30 seconds before and then I
think we all kind of went a little white
and some think I don't know Claudie or
carla bruni
unlike you guys we have done shows
before my it's been a while you know
what we're doing
into that and Cindy certainly knows what
she's doing when it comes to furniture
design - she's celebrating 10 years of
Cindy Crawford home at the break when
you think about the fact that you
started this little project and here you
are with a successful brand as an
entrepreneur that must have a lot of
value for you you know what I love about
doing Cindy Crawford home and partnering
with the brick is that it's doing
furniture at this point in my life isn't
so much more reflective of you know who
I am as a 51 year old woman who's you
know of course I was a model for years
but I'm a wife I'm a mother I'm someone
who cares about creating a beautiful
environment for my family and I love
that doing furniture has allowed you
know it's grown with me and she also
wants to create a beautiful environment
for her famous friends which of course
includes George Clooney who created a
tequila with Cindy's husband Randy
called Cass amigos
you know I saw your buddy recently
George Clooney and he showed me pictures
of his kids
I'm about to cry okay looks like mommy
looks like you are you gonna check right
I'm getting emotional right now dude
there he's a thug get me an even offered
me custom egos which he never gave that
to me George I'm here with somebody I
need to get sup does george share
stories about the kids funny moments I
have I I saw we went Randy and I went to
London to see them right after their
babies were born and then by the time
they got to LA we had left so I haven't
you know I have a few little email
exchanges but I'm looking forward to
meeting them now that they're more than
a week goal
congratulations yeah great ten years so
sure about this why not I love the soil
is very soft it is yeah we could totally
lean back and realize they were kicking
back where's the cuss amigos I need some
caffeine yeah